Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jake:有一种这个粉色的感觉
Jake: There’s this kind of pink feeling
Katrina: 这这这是确实粉紫色的
Katrina: This, this, this is really pink-purple
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Shure: 雨轩现在要不帮忙叫一下吧
Shure: Yuxuan, why not help call out now
Jake:感觉到了
Jake: Got it
Katrina: 全是紫色的
Katrina: It’s all purple
Shure: 帮忙叫一下
Shure: Help call out
Shure: 都鸭嗓子了
Shure: My voice is hoarse
Jake:来两位帮忙帮个忙吧
Jake: Come on, you two, give us a hand
Shure: 你要不私闯进去
Shure: Why don’t you just barge in
Jake:弹了给个背景音
Jake: Play some background music
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear
Katrina: 不在
Katrina: Not here
Jake:不在
Jake: Not here
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:在外边吗难道
Jake: Are they outside?
Jake:哎呀哎呀
Jake: Oh dear, oh dear
Katrina: 哎呀哎呀
Katrina: Oh dear, oh dear
Katrina: 瞎吧
Katrina: Blind, right?
Shure: 我寻思得睡多死啊
Shure: I’m thinking, how dead asleep must they be
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死
Katrina: Hahaha, laughing to death
Katrina: 我的心
Katrina: Oh my heart
Jake:在还是不在啊
Jake: Are they here or not
Katrina: 不在啊
Katrina: Not here
Jake:不不在啊
Jake: Not, not here?
Katrina: 床上没有人啊
Katrina: There’s no one on the bed
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Shure: 那她去哪了
Shure: Where did she go?
Jake:问问
Jake: Ask around
Katrina: 偶买噶增加一点悬疑的情节唉
Katrina: Oh my God, add a bit of suspense to the plot
Jake:这剧本挺好啊
Jake: This script is pretty good
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:是在这吗
Jake: Are they here?
Jake:是在厕所吗
Jake: Are they in the bathroom?
Jake:会吗
Jake: Could they be?
Katrina: 厕所他也会回答我们呀
Katrina: If they were in the bathroom, they would answer us
Jake:那应该得听见是吧
Jake: Then we should be able to hear, right?
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah
Katrina: 哈哈这一唱太有性缩力了
Katrina: Haha, this singing is so full of "sex shrinkage."
Katrina: 我的天
Katrina: Oh my god.
Shure: 性缩力是什么意思
Shure: What does "sex shrinkage" mean?
Katrina: 性张力的反义
Katrina: It's the opposite of "sexual tension."
Katrina: 不见了吗露亚
Katrina: Has Lucia disappeared?
Jake:他去卫生所了
Jake: He went to the clinic.
Katrina: 怎么了不舒服啊
Katrina: What's wrong? Not feeling well?
Jake:他呃去玩狗的时候被狗抓了一下
Jake: He, uh, got scratched by a dog while playing with it.
Jake:他不放心
Jake: He was worried.
Jake:打疫苗去了
Jake: Went to get vaccinated.
Alice:去哪打了呀
Alice: Where did he get it?
Jake:就附近的一个卫生所
Jake: Just at a nearby clinic.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's up?
Katrina: 你要等他回吗
Katrina: Are you going to wait for him to come back?
Jake:不用了
Jake: No need.
Katrina: 直接我们讨论
Katrina: Let's just start discussing.
Shure: 加了我食指中间
Shure: Added to my index finger.
Jake:对直接讨论
Jake: Yeah, let's just discuss.
Katrina: OK啊开始吧
Katrina: OK, let's start.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:唉还有一个人没选会没出来了
Jake: Oh, there's one more person who hasn't chosen yet.
Shure: Natasha
Shure: Natasha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 乌日啦mother rush
Shure: Wurila mother rush.
Shure: i need you
Shure: I need you.
Katrina: 感觉骂的很脏
Katrina: Sounds like he's cursing.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: ralish
Shure: Ralish.
Shure: 好的傻
Shure: Alright, silly.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Katrina: 越来越抽象了
Katrina: It's getting more abstract.
Jake:抽象确实抽象
Jake: Abstract, indeed abstract.
Katrina: 我那个香薰还蛮香的
Katrina: My aroma diffuser is quite fragrant.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure: 我让他给我占个位置
Shure: I asked him to save me a spot.
Alice:塔莎
Alice: Tasha.
Alice:早上好
Alice: Good morning.
Shure: 塔莎 早上好
Shure: Tasha, good morning.
Shure: 乌日朗
Shure: Good morning.
Alice:早上好
Alice: Good morning.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Shure: 你没有听过二手玫瑰吗
Shure: Haven't you heard of the band Second-hand Rose?
Katrina: 跟谁说话呢
Katrina: Who are you talking to?
Shure: 跟你啊
Shure: You, of course.
Katrina: 应该听过吧
Katrina: I think I have.
Alice:二手玫瑰哎
Alice: Second-hand Rose, huh.
Jake:唉  门开了
Jake: Hey, the door is open.
Shure: 门开了
Shure: The door is open.
Jake:但是
Jake: But...
Shure: 但是什么
Shure: But what?
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where is everyone?
Shure: 这首歌叫啥呀
Shure: What's the name of this song?
Shure: 谜底写在谜面上了是吗
Shure: Is the answer in the riddle itself?
Katrina: 呃给你点小小的安比震撼
Katrina: Uh, let me give you a little surprise.
Shure: 哎我还
Shure: Hey, I still...
Shure: 我好像还会唱那个
Shure: I think I can still sing that one.
Katrina: 定一下歌呗
Katrina: Let's decide on a song.
Alice:能不能来一个听了之后不困的歌
Alice: Can we play a song that won't make us sleepy?
Katrina: 但我不太会唱啊
Katrina: But I don't really know how to sing it.
Katrina: 我上次去成都
Katrina: Last time I went to Chengdu...
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Katrina: 又来刺激我是吧
Katrina: You're trying to provoke me again, huh?
Katrina: 你要知道
Katrina: You know...
Katrina: 晚上的我跟白天的我不是同一个人
Katrina: The me at night is not the same as the me during the day.
Alice:啥玩意
Alice: What do you mean?
Katrina: 斯班当时他们乐队有唱
Katrina: Their band sang this back then.
Katrina: 但是我不太会唱
Katrina: But I don't really know how to sing it.
Shure: 很简单
Shure: It's very simple.
Jake:我先把这个关了
Jake: Let me turn this off first.
Jake:然后再给你开
Jake: Then I'll turn it back on for you.
Jake:他要重启一下比较好
Jake: It needs a restart to work better.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 没插音箱吧怎么这么大声音
Katrina: Didn't plug in the speakers? Why is it so loud?
Jake:没有 让 我现在去揉
Jake: No, let me go fix it now.
Jake:这个我先放你这里边
Jake: I'll put this here for you first.
Jake:然后你暂时先不用充电
Jake: And you don't need to charge it right now.
Katrina: 唉 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Katrina: Hey, dudududududu.
Jake:然后一会充电在拿
Jake: Then charge it later and pick it up.
Tasha:今天是在这偷的是吧
Tasha: So, we're stealing here today, right?
Jake:对外边冷了
Jake: Yeah, it's cold outside.
Shure: 唱不下去太高了
Shure: I can't keep singing, it's too high.
Shure: 我们可以唱一点简单
Shure: Let's sing something simpler.
Shure: 你们有听过朴树的new boy吗
Shure: Have you heard Pu Shu's "New Boy"?
Shure: 就是这一首
Shure: It's this one.
Katrina: 那肯定听过 呵呵呵
Katrina: Of course I've heard it, hahaha.
Jake:这朴树的
Jake: It's by Pu Shu.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 另一个
Katrina: Another one.
Shure: 另一个
Shure: Another one.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 咦什么人
Shure: Huh, who is that?
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What is it?
Jake:你看见过
Jake: Have you seen it?
Katrina: 你明天早上就
Katrina: Tomorrow morning, you'll...
Katrina: 把我们叫醒然后就坐这弹然后我们就醒了
Katrina: Wake us up, then sit here and play, and we'll wake up.
Katrina: 一下可以叫醒三个
Katrina: You can wake up three at once.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 我直接开始国际歌起来
Shure: I'll start with the Internationale.
Jake:国际歌用吉他合适合不合适
Jake: Is the Internationale suitable for guitar?
Shure: 合适
Shure: Suitable.
Jake:合适
Jake: Suitable.
修硕能:能唱我们我们
Shure: Can we sing it?
Shure: 主要是看我们能不能唱
Shure: The main thing is if we can sing it.
Jake:能唱能唱
Jake: We can sing it.
Jake:国际歌怎么了
Jake: What's wrong with the Internationale?
Jake:你又没唱
Jake: You haven't sung it.
Jake:算了呵
Jake: Forget it, haha.
Shure: 呵我知道你想说什么
Shure: Haha, I know what you're trying to say.
Shure: 杨老板你很危险
Shure: Jake, you're very dangerous.
Jake:你不知道
Jake: You don't know.
Shure: 我真不知道吗
Shure: Do I really not know?
Jake:你知道
Jake: You know.
Shure: 我该不该知道呢
Shure: Should I know?
Jake:我不知道你知不知道
Jake: I don't know if you know.
Katrina: 唱
Katrina: Sing.
Shure: 唱什么国际歌吗
Shure: Sing the international song?
Jake:来
Jake: Go ahead.
Shure: 我找一张谱子
Shure: I'll find some sheet music.
Katrina: 所以我们在等待什么
Katrina: So what are we waiting for?
Shure: 我在等待
Shure: I'm waiting.
Jake:唉
Jake: Sigh.
Shure: 塔莎戴眼镜
Shure: Tasha's wearing glasses.
Jake:哈哈对啊
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:你在干哈
Jake: What are you doing?
Shure: 起来  哎呀
Shure: Get up. Oh man.
Jake:你在里边吗
Jake: Are you inside?
Jake:他不在里面
Jake: He's not inside.
Jake:他哪去了
Jake: Where did he go?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你以后跟我说
Katrina: Tell me next time.
Katrina: 要带一个那个GPS模块了
Katrina: We should bring a GPS module.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 是不是
Katrina: Right?
Jake:人均
Jake: Everyone.
Katrina: 哈哈哈人均丢失一次
Katrina: Hahaha, everyone gets lost at least once.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:我刚刚想说一个人的名字
Jake: I was just about to mention someone's name.
Jake:但是不敢说
Jake: But I didn't dare.
Jake:算了
Jake: Never mind.
Shure: 不对这个谱子有问题
Shure: No, there's a problem with this sheet music.
Shure: 在臭美什么    咦
Shure: What are you showing off for? Ew.
Katrina: 自拍一下
Katrina: Just taking a selfie.
Shure: 给那个人发是吧好好好
Shure: Sending it to that person, right? Okay, okay.
Katrina: 不是不是
Katrina: No, no.
Shure: 不是 啊 不是 啊
Shure: No? Oh, no?
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina: 不是
Katrina: No.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ahhhhh.
Shure: 嗯嗯嗯嗯
Shure: Mmmm.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 好听
Katrina: Sounds good.
Shure: 好听
Shure: Sounds good.
Shure: 让我再看你一眼
Shure: Let me take another look at you.
Shure: 从南到北
Shure: From south to north.
Katrina: 从南到北
Katrina: From south to north
Shure: 没没没没没
Shure: No, no, no, no, no
Shure: 你看过那个吗
Shure: Have you seen that one?
Shure: 羊头版的那个
Shure: The one with the goat's head
Shure: 安和桥
Shure: Anhe Bridge
Katrina: 这歌叫什么
Katrina: What's the name of this song?
Shure: new boy
Shure: New Boy
Katrina: 哎new boy
Katrina: Oh, New Boy
Katrina: 哦那就唱这个呗
Katrina: Oh, then let's sing this one
Shure: 他他
Shure: He, he
Shure: 这个歌还有一个同样调的另一个版本
Shure: There's another version of this song with the same tune
Shure: 叫什么
Shure: What's it called?
Shure: 曾曾经怎么说
Shure: How did it go... once upon a time...
Shure: 唉我草我忘了
Shure: Ah, damn, I forgot
Katrina: AI在注视你
Katrina: AI is watching you
Shure: 哦叫forever young
Shure: Oh, it's called Forever Young
Shure: 就是一样的调
Shure: It's the same tune
Shure: 但是它的词儿不一样那个是
Shure: But the lyrics are different, that one is
Jake:我在揉面
Jake: I'm kneading dough
Katrina: 你在揉面
Katrina: You're kneading dough
Jake:对你们把曲子定了吧
Jake: Yeah, you guys decide on the song
Jake:你们仨把曲子定了吧
Jake: You three decide on the song
Katrina: 所以说我把开会流程变成我们三个了
Katrina: So, I turned the meeting into just the three of us
Jake:我把这
Jake: I'll...
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Shure: 然后就是把曲子定一下就好
Shure: So we just need to decide on the song
Jake:曲子定一下
Jake: Decide on the song
Katrina: 谁会唱歌
Katrina: Who can sing?
Jake:明天明天安排
Jake: Tomorrow, we'll arrange it
Katrina: 柯欣你唱吗
Katrina: Ke Xin, can you sing?
Jake:明明天明天探探走一遍明
Jake: Tomorrow, we'll go through it once
Katrina: 咱搞一个合唱呗就不跳舞了
Katrina: Let's do a chorus, no dancing
Alice:我
Alice: Me
Jake:对明天探探和
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow we'll rehearse
Jake:就是其实明天就是彩排
Jake: Tomorrow is basically the rehearsal
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Jake:和收视方面
Jake: And the viewership aspects
Katrina: 唱呗不然就我们两个
Katrina: Let's sing, otherwise it'll just be the two of us
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Shure: 我们俩唱
Shure: The two of us will sing
Katrina: 多尴尬啊
Katrina: How embarrassing!
Shure: 唱素颜 哈哈哈
Shure: Sing "Bare Face" hahaha
Katrina: 我们两个直接唱破音
Katrina: The two of us will totally go off-key.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:唱对
Jake: Sing it right.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 哎素颜很适合
Katrina: Hey, "Bare Face" is very suitable.
Katrina: 吉他那个耶
Katrina: For guitar, yeah.
Shure: 好像是
Shure: Seems like it.
Jake:那你们聊聊
Jake: Then you guys chat.
Jake:然后彩排也聊一聊
Jake: And let's chat during the rehearsal too.
Katrina: 搞个节目
Katrina: Let's make a show.
Katrina: 我感觉唱歌比唱歌可以唱个俩
Katrina: I feel like singing is better, we could sing two songs.
Jake:我我们揉完应该就上来了
Jake: Once we finish kneading, we should be ready.
Jake:也揉个20分钟吧
Jake: Let's knead for about 20 minutes.
Katrina: 唱个大家都会的国歌
Katrina: Let's sing a national anthem that everyone knows.
Shure: 你你怎么这么疯呢
Shure: Why are you so crazy?
Katrina: 我我是火象星座
Katrina: I'm a fire sign.
Shure: 你火象星座你也不会违
Shure: Even if you're a fire sign, you can't break the law.